pierre garde à vue sous toutes ses
coutures
l'interview de claude lanzmann mise en
image par guy seligmann prendre cinq
minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les fouriéristes de mode parle
froidement aujourd'hui et sans se
soucier des abus de langage de l'empiré
garde
il est exact que la griffe gardin
déchire le monde de tokyo à new york en
passant par l'europe l'amérique latine
et même les inte
on assiste à une multiplication non
miraculeuse des boutiques garde 1 300 en
angleterre 281 en france
198 en allemagne 97 en italie 43 en
espagne trente mille personnes et sans
trois usines travaillent pour pierre
cardin après avoir habillé les femmes
puis les hommes quart d'heure vient
d'annexer les enfants il médite sûrement
d'autres conquêtes identifié à toutes
les audaces
son nom est maintenant associé à la
production et à la consommation de masse
partout et de la tête à l'orteil
on peut s'habiller gardien c'est ce
phénomène de cardy nisation galopante
dont nous sommes à la fois les témoins
et les victimes que nous avons tenté
d'élucider il y à 25 ans à vichy qui
regarde un employé de la croix rouge
française s'occupait de l'aide
intellectuelle aux prisonniers de guerre
aujourd'hui dans son hôtel particulier
du quai anatole france à paris il nous
conte l'histoire de son cheminement et
détermine les frontières de son empire
voici donc cardin l'empereur pierre
cardin une chose me frappe
vous parlez très souvent de vous à la
troisième personne pourquoi c'est à dire
oui moi je suis dans le fond un élément
j'estime qu'à partir du moment où ce
n'est pas mon travail direct
je suis une troisième personne si vous
laissez mon nom c'est mon nom à travers
mes créations mais ce n'est plus en tant
que personnalité en tant que personne
humaine
je ne peux pas dire que c'est moi qui
fais telle ou telle chose puisque c'est
la griffe en elle-même donc la griffe
est une méthode et une troisième
dimension en face n'est plus moi c'est
vous tous ces mois travaux départ mais
par la suite sont des reproductions par
conséquent c'est le fruit de la création
ce n'est plus le fruit d'un individu au
départ c'est moi mais lorsque je parle
de mon affaire et de mon nom et de mes
possibilités dans le monde entier
si vous voulez je suis abstrait dans moi
même enfin c'est une chose qui devient
une chose que merci ça absolument c'est
plus - ciblant ce n'est plus mais ce
n'est plus mon départ c'est à dire la
partie créative où je suis là avec mes
mannequins que je maintiens mon crayon
entendu dire également
je trouve ça très intéressant ça n'est
pas de la polémique que nous faisons
c'est pour comprendre non mais j'essaie
je le voulais et d'entendre dire quand
pierre cardin n'existait pas là aussi
c'est une façon de parler de vous la
troisième quand vous rendra et si je
disparais il est certain que que le
problème soit différent non c'est pas ça
non au détour d'une phrase il avait dit
quand pierre cardin n'existait pas et ce
qui me frappe c'est que vous êtes un
vrai chef
je suis un chef d'entreprise indiens par
quinzaine cette vie qui se prend pour un
autre
un chef oui enfin je me prend combien
carnage
oui ma montagne au bord du canal en même
temps quand vous parlez des entreprises
picardes
vous parlez de pierre carles et bien
parce que je ne suis plus seule à ce
moment là et que j'ai des collaborateurs
et cela n'aura eu peur d'une institution
excellent collaborateur m'aide beaucoup
je d'ailleurs c'est vrai c'est
impossible autrement comment voulez vous
à quel âge vous avez commencé seul à 4
15 ans je vous dis 16 ans ça venait de
l'enfance en charge et pas des parents
qui sont disposés en u dessus
mes parents sont était d'aider des
origines italiennes nous sommes je vous
le dis donc par conséquent les parents
étaient dès les premières glacial et de
l'hommiste et les terriens il avait des
vignes il avait et transport fut la
guerre de 14 et ils ont tout perdu
jeunes enfants de vieux moi mon père
avait avec cinq ans plus de 50 ans quand
je suis venu au monde et ma mère
quarante six ans c'est beaucoup et vous
c'est beaucoup de lentille 100 ch vous
êtes né où je suis né près de venise
dans une maison de campagne ou un parent
avait là bas oui c'était une vraie
maison de campagne
enfin c'était pas une maison de campagne
ce qui devient assez j'ai une maison je
l'aimais en fait c'est vous avez toute
la réussite ou non de toute l'italie
pratiquement les maisons de campagne en
en ferait des maisons plaisir alors
c'est tellement c'est beau il n'y a pas
de mérite sont des vieilles maisons qui
sont payantes telles classes en soi même
que je n'ai rien dit de ferme
oui mais c'était quand même une ferme de
fonséranes faire non pas du tout c'est
une très bonne maison et vous êtes venu
à paris vous même à quel âge en fera un
mois j'étais un bébé presque dans l'air
presque oncle ortel enfin je marchais
ils ont quitté l'italie pourquoi la
suite des événements de guerre les
parents étaient réfugiées en sicile l'un
quand ils sont revenus dans leur pays en
venise ils tous leurs atouts leur a été
des allemands avaient passé vous savez
le pot tout ça tout a été dévasté
ils ont tout perdu
pères enfin c'était le désastre après la
guerre et puis on voit le peu d'argent
quand on leur a donné tout a été démoli
les maisons tout ce qu'il possédait un
découragement total et mes parents sont
venus à l'école ici en france pour
décourager influent comment faire et et
à ces mesures n'avaient jamais travaillé
de sa vie il avait été un fils de enfin
comme tous les gens les terriens ne
travaillait pas avant les gens qui
habitaient la campagne ça dépend quel
terrien mais enfin je veux dire que vous
avez dans les parents des biens quand
vous avez déjà été rien on va y être
allé les fils non permanents aurait
peut-être 95 presque cent ans on est 50
et 95 à conséquent à cette époque 1900
1910 1890 les gens felicis ne travaillez
pas enfin ils étaient les fils de
propriété oui croyez pas mon père a
commencé à travailler à trets ma
naissance ans après la guerre et qu'est
ce qu'il a fait en france
oh le pauvre rien du tout était si
furieux après qu'est ce que voulez qu'il
fasse presque rien oui vous avez enfin
on sait que moi j'ai mon père 45 ans 45
ans quand j'avais 10 ans ils avaient soi
quand j'avais quinze élèves de 60 ans
travailler plus je suis un enfant de
pauvre si vous voulez c'est ce que je
voulais vous demander donnant sa peau
puisque m'épuise ont tout perdu donc
vous savez eu une enfance qu enfin j'ai
eu une enfance pour mais j'ai eu des
dérapages et élevé dans les conditions
ci voulait moral et
et les d'une manière bien je suppose
qu'on peut être mais mais bien sûr mais
je veux dire dans quel sens où vous
l'entendez prochain oui on a le radar
gens du tout j'avais pas d'argent quand
j'étais enfant du tout du tout pas du
tout mes parents je vous dis ont tout
perdu par la garde 14 mai arrière grands
parents on a tout perdu et quand on ans
après vous savez la dévaluation de
l'argent une maison un jour julien
j'habitais à sa une mais la maison
valait 60 mille soixante mille francs en
1936 39 60 mille francs c'était une
maison vous rendez compte on assumer
dans 68 francs qu'est ce que c'est
maintenant 100 d'huile france j'ai même
pas même pas je dis pas une chaise est à
l'origine de votre italienne monsieur de
régiment basé à comprend bien l'origine
de votre vocation de couturier
il avait commandé six mois que je me
suis entraîné quand j'étais enfant
j'aimais jouer de l'équipe us que tu es
droite est que mon jeu j'ai aimé jouer
mon
mon idéal et m avec des poupées ou des
romains oui je leur ai deja ben je
pensais jamais qu'un jour ces robes
deviendra une réalité je le souhaitais
d'un subconscient mai mais dans le fond
je ne savais pas je ne savais pas ce que
c'était qu'être couturier je ne savais
même pas je disais je voulais être
couturier à l'orientation
je me souviens j'avais 14 à 13 12 ans on
me demandait à l'année à l'école qu'est
ce que vous aimeriez plus tard du
couturier mais je sais même pas ce que
c'est être couturier jeudi être
couturier en province penser à 13 ans
après 12 ans même peut être dix ans je
ne pourrais pas donner une date exacte
comment quand avez vous commencé alors à
pratiquer et bien j'ai pratiqué vraiment
je vais pratiquer mon métier vraiment
que j'ai commencé à quimper
saint-etienne et puis à vichy quand
après j'ai fait des stades à la part aux
françaises en fait j'ai travaillé chez
regoli puisque mes chéris colis je
voulais dit tout à l'heure je m'occupais
de les dater dès que le prisonnier de
guerre mais en tant que couturier mais
je ne vais pas couturier un soir je
faisais de des écritures c'est ça je
faisais des écritures et apprend à
saint-etienne même vous savez très bien
ce garçon puisque j'ai dit et
saint-etienne un large 16 ans et demi 17
ans à la guerre il a fallu fuir puisque
les ânes on avait des parfums était prêt
dès pas si la ligne démarcation et et
j'ai fuit dans le maquis je suis arrivé
j'ai échoué à vichy car je voulais
monter à paris et à paris innocent et
pure que j' étais malgré des
circonstances politiques et grave de la
guerre
j'ai pensé qu'elle allait tout
simplement passer le pont de moulins et
j'étais arrêté par les allemands m'hamid
enfin deux jours dans une
dans une chambre de la gare et on a
vérifié tous mes papiers innocent non
j'ai cru que j'allais pouvoir monter en
pleine guerre à paris tellement j'avais
envie de travailler dans le métier de la
structure et puis pas du tout j'étais
chez dress à vichy j'ai donc fait demi
tour et je me suis dit covès faire je
vais essayer de trouver une place dans
la haute couture à paris et j'ai dû
rentrer chez lego league était à ce
moment là la première maison de vichy où
on habillait toutes les personnalités
importantes de vichy en passant par of
par les hommes politiques par les
ambassadeurs etc sous vichy sous
l'occupation de l'époque pétain
seulement gagner et bien pendant la
guerre vichy c'était la cab vient sur
place et en quelle année en 42 eh bien
écoutez c'était en 40 41 la guerre c 42
ne sais pas où 45 40 45 45
et bien renault où la libération de
paris s'est fait ravir est toujours à
l'apa rouge française j'étais le dernier
employé de la croix-rouge français y
avait 800 foyers
j'ai assisté là j'ai fait la liquidation
de la croix rouge française tous les
employés puisque j'étais au service de
direction auprès du du docteur richard
et du général verdict était le délégué
général la croix rouge française à ce
moment-là et
angers était le dernier employé puisque
j'étais au service de direction et je
etherea pas rapatrié à paris par les
camions de la croix rouge française
c'est à dire au mois d'octobre 45
je vais vous raconter le plus
extraordinaire c'est qu'on avait des
restes d'un tailleur à paris qui était
faubourg saint-honoré que je ne
connaissais absolument pas j'arrive à
paris
rapatrié par l'apa rouge parle les
camions un samedi soir je vais me
coucher et être est fort tard le
dimanche matin à 9 heures je me la
leggia froid terrible personne n'en
paris dans le faubourg saint honoré
j'habitais rue d'hygiène dans un hôtel
où j'ai bouché une nuit je prends la rue
saint-honoré
je vais je la trouvais tellement long
quand on est à la recherche de quelqu'un
c'est tellement long plus le faubourg
saint-honoré qui prenons la rue
saint-honoré
je vois lanvin qui était toujours pour
moi mon idéal à ce moment là je m'arrête
devant la boutique de lanvin et dans ce
désert du faubourg je vois arriver un
monsieur jeudi côté monsieur ce que fout
on dit si le 81 2 est loin d'ici le 10
qui cherchez vous 90 il me dit jeudi que
des joueurs se cherchent tel monsieur il
me dit c'est moi donc je suis arrivé à
paris à la recherche d'un monsieur qui
pouvait m'aider à rentrer chez paquin
puisque c'est par ce monsieur là que je
devais rentrer chez chacun je demande à
la première personne à qui j'adresse la
parole en arrivant après la guerre ne
connaisse un baril une seule personne je
demande mon chemin c'est la personne qui
me donne c'est elle que je cherchais ça
c'est assez extraordinaire le signe des
grands destins
c'est très intéressant parce que c'est
ce qu'on appelle la montée à paris
contre la montre est exact martin dès la
fin de la guerre des paris c'était pour
moi la découverte et est ce que
représente le rêve de paris je suis donc
entré chez paquin et là on est rentré on
vous a engagé en tant que poids employés
ouvriers ouvriers et moi même je ne veux
même pas élémentaire tout à fait cousant
je n'avais pas du tout la prétention
d'être ni à me des listes ni ni à
dessinateur ni un coupeur quand ton âme
j'en veux quand on avait l'âge que
j'avais à cette époque là je voulais
avant tout je serais rentré même ce soir
j'aurais fait n'importe quoi vous
rentrez si maintenant on désire était
grande rentrée j'ai paquin et là à ce
moment la chance a voulu que monsieur
crise monsieur jean cocteau
monsieur bérard était en train de
préparer les costumes de la belle et la
bête vous pensé pour moi la chance
inespérée
en plus de cela les a faits dans
l'atelier où s'étaient alors adorant le
costume adhérents théâtre cinéma quand
on a vu ça immédiatement gelé par
instinct j'ai voulu faire cela et je les
ai immédiatement compris ses costumes
monsieur jean marais était en suisse à
ce moment là et il fallait faire des
essayages
il s'est trouvé que on m'a remarquée
dans l'atelier où j'étais j'ai paquin et
au made man on a fait descendre dans les
salons pour faire tous les costumes
essayé sur moi par monsieur bérard et
monsieur jean cocteau en tant qu' en
tant que les mensonges mannequin ciblé
j'étais un des premiers vingt deux cas
si vous êtes paris en somme on avait
tous les ja sur moi je n'avais pas la
taille de jean marais douanes là enfin
j'étais si bien un gabarit un tout petit
peu plus plus petit membre va on
pourrait faire en tout cas tous les
essais et ensuite on a été plus qu'à les
mettre aux mesures mais les maîtres
mesure étant donné que c'était moi qui
ai fait le con tinue prince et cossu de
la bête si vous voulez le costume même
de michel auclair avec qui était le père
à ce moment là de nous des 6000 à perly
il y avait jose et b enfin vous
connaissez sûrement vu ce film
par conséquent je d'etel m'en fous mais
quand j'en rêvais la nuit et que on a
tellement monsieur bérard a reçu comme
toi monsieur aurait tous ces gens qui
travaillaient pour le film du marché des
scpi ont des noms vu mon enthousiasme
pour pour faire ce travail que
automatiquement on a remarqué en face à
soi quelqu'un qui est saint céré qui est
enthousiaste et on m'a demandé à ce
moment là et j'ai fait ces costumes et
c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré
quelques tous ces gens de briand à ce
moment là qui pour moi représente et le
top de paris
exécuter les costumes et envie d'essayer
votre corps ces stars et en suisse
lorsque au bout d'un certain temps
j'étais tout de même conscient tout en
étant très humble je détiens conscient
de ce que je voulais ce que je faisais
mais je vive enfin je ne vais pas rester
dans son atelier si vous voulez j'ai
immédiatement je suis rentré chez scapa
raid et j'ai quitté pas qu'un jeu du
racing a ouvert sa maison en novembre
1946 avenue matignon est épuisée et
après je la maison à prix prestige que
vous savez c'est de me l'apprendre
maison mondiale et puis au bout de deux
ans il ya une histoire assez à ces
fâcheuses qui m'a beaucoup peiné car
pour moi dur c'était ma vie quelle
histoire face au moment de suite de
modèle à ce moment c'est 250 et
insoupçonnées que peut-être j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu manoeuvrer une manière
indélicate et leur linge était
extrêmement peiné immédiatement j'ai
donné ma démission j'ai quitté dior
trois mois prévu ce que j'avais j'étais
un cadre avancé quand j'ai du show
bourgeot quitter et ça a été
pratiquement même une réussite parce qu
une chance pour moi parce que il n'y
aurait pas eu ce cas précis je serai
peut-être encore chez christian dior
j'avais aucune raison de quitter la
maison dior rupture béni n'est ce pas en
1950 pressentiez vous la suite il y
avait aucune raison ou des parcs jeu que
j'ai cette réussite aucune raison fait
ma condition sociale
le cias unis mais mes possibilités
intellectuelles du moment ne permettait
pas du tout non visage est une réussite
aussi extraordinaire c'est ce que vous
appelez vos possibilités intellectuelles
et bien ma formation culturelle si vous
voulez du début puisque je suis assez
élémentaire c'est à dire je n'avais pas
fait des études comme tous mes camarades
du bureau étaient tous désignent à l'apa
rouge des tous les licenciés le moindre
envoyé collègue l'avait plus ou moins
échange de droits accès à moi n'a aucune
licence j'étais vraiment très
élémentaire en tant que formation mais
vous saviez de l'ambition j'ai eu
l'ambition j'en avais pas eu d'ambition
je n'aurais je n'aurais sûrement pas
persévéré je n'aurais sûrement pas fait
ce qu'il fallait faire et surtout
travailler comme je le fais j'avais de
l'ambition mais c'est une qualité pour
moi mais je le prends bien comme cela
mais vous saviez un moteur en feu oui
j'avais une croyance en moins très
grande force oui je j'avais une croyance
en moi je marchais droit et avec une
force et une volonté et entraînant
d'ailleurs autour de moi je suis
extrêmement exigeant
je demande le maximum la soluce il veut
dans tout vous êtes pitoyable à vous
trouver
oui je suis très sensible et je suis
très près des gens des gens de toutes
conditions sociales et humaines
d'ailleurs très très près je les
comprends très bien pour moi même je
suis une condition très simple donc
justement je mets toujours dans l'état
d'esprit les autres je crois que mes
employés je pense que je suis légal avec
une ouvrière qu'avec mme al amal 127
électrices enfin je crois pas qu'il ya
un changement de deux personnalités ans
- non je suis très vrai vous êtes le
même de fonzie guerre absolument oui ça
joue franc jeu en élections absolument
j'ai parfois très souvent même plus de
plus de compréhension pour des gens qui
ne sont pas ce qu'il peut être qu'ils
n'ont pas ce qu'ils méritent exactement
qui pourrait être plus et qui par la
condition de peut-être en effet parce
qu'ils n'osent pas lutter qui
malheureusement les mélanger conditions
sociales élémentaire mai
je comprends bien les gens je m'y
intéresse beaucoup est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres secteurs d'activités que vous
souhaitez explorer ou dans la situation
de mon métier je crois que j'ai a
pratiquement atteint le maximum
jean luc se prolonger mais par allah par
l'importance de mon nom mais je ne crois
pas non parce qu il semble clair que
vous ayez à côté annexionnistes n'ont
jamais rien vu non gm gm faisait déjà
possédé et pas du tout pour procéder
parce que dans le fond je stresse un
vrai je veux dire que dans le fond
l'approprient l'instinct de propriété ne
pour moi ne m'appartient pas je peux
très bien vivre très solitaire et vivre
avec la d'ailleurs je vis très
simplement et très sobrement c'est très
public enfin ce qui vu leur part il me
voit jamais brillé aussi je prie c'est
pour les autres mais ce n'est pas pour
moi oui j'ai besoin de rien s'il voulait
moins à vis ma condition humaine n'a
fait que je peux vivre très sobrement
très simplement dans ma vie sociale
j'exige qu'elle soit la hauteur de mon
métier mais en tant que condition
personnelle je vis très simplement avec
une personne qui est une gouvernante qui
est marié et il combien de fois il
m'arrive de samedi à dimanche deux de
manger de faire moi même je n'ai pas
mangé un bout de fromage s'agit très
simplement je le luxe et pour les autres
ce n'est pas pour moi je suis exigeant
parce que je suis du cnam de luxe pour
les autres mais pour moi je vis très
simplement le luxe ne manque
ça ne mange pas si vous voulez je les
fais pour les autres enfin pour pas pour
les autres pour la réussite de main de
mon nom nom de réponse par les
impérialismes ce ne voulait pas dire du
tout que vous capitalise y est pour nous
et pas traîné puisque
kaboul capitale ici les hauts cris ou
des biens matériels
je voulais dire est ce que les
entreprises car devront s'étendre à
d'autres sectes d'activité oui tout ce
qui est création par exemple sera grave
de dessiner des voitures oui j'aimerais
beaucoup dessiner des voitures je crois
que les voitures sont pas leur maximum
ou si vous aussi bien transparente que
en caoutchouc entièrement enfin je
soutiens et non des formes uniquement
purement sûrement dans mon imagination
j'irai pas abstrait puisqu'elles ne sont
actuellement mais dans les formes
différentes que je crois que c'est
intéressant pour un enfant j'aime créer
si vous dire être dessiné des tables des
bugs des objets des lampes 20 tout ce
qui est création m'intéresse vous
parlait toujours de création est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas un peu à force à de la
création
il n'y at il pas là une carte gratuite
et d'arbitré vous faites du neuf pour
faire du neuf
absolument rien dessus je suis obligé
sinon je serais un habilleur on n'aurait
pas besoin des créateurs des couturiers
c'était pour faire des robes très bien
fait les robes qui sont déjà acceptés
quel intérêt d'attendre couturière dans
le monde qui travaille merveilleusement
bien qu'ils essayent merveilleusement
bien
ce plan demande un grand couturier n'est
pas de faire une très belle robe bien
essayé bien fait on lui demande de
modifier la face du monde par la
structure du vêtement par la coupée par
la ligne c'est cela le rôle d'un grand
couturier ce n'est pas de faire une
jolie robe bien fait ça il ya des
milliers de personnes qui savent le
faire dans tous les pays du monde la
mode doit absolument tenir compte
d'aucun facteurs et d'aucune critique
elle est là pour modifier et pour faire
vendre et pour faire travailler des
millions d'êtres dans le monde
c'est ça le but essentiel de la mode ce
n'est pas de vendre des robes pour
quelques femmes privilégient qui ont
beaucoup d'argent et qui sont riches pas
du tout c'est de faire travailler
n'importe quelle petite ouvrière pour
qu'elle puisse vivre si imaginer qu'on
supprime la mode commencera habiller les
femmes comment combien de gens sont au
chômage
en commençant par les photographes les
radios la télévision commencer par les
représentants et les voyages commencer
par les ouvrières les machines
écrit même les machines à coudre
c'est démentiel le fil la soie le coton
qu'il faudrait toujours sa vie
non ça m'irait moins souvent mais les
genres est moins d'aisance tout de même
pour vivre et vous pensez que la
structure du corps est modifiée elle
même un sûrement un corps un couturier
moi quand j'ai débuté dans le métier
les mannequins paradant avec acs était
tellement serré tallio new look puisque
j'ai commencé au new look sdp n'en dirai
qu'elle marchait comme ça ensuite on les
a fait marcher comme ça le ventre en
avant
ensuite on les a fait marcher tout à
fait droite n'est ce pas vraiment très
droit et ensuite est venu le côté
décontracté naturel de la vie de
maintenant parce que les robes sont le
niveau parce que votre corps libéré
parce qu'elles ont une manière marché
qui est naturelle et décontractée
je mets le corps le couturier modifie le
corps les médecins vous le diront en 19
ans les hommes ou les femmes se
déplaçait comme ça car il avait des
coups très haut des coûts ont pesé des
détenus 13 ans très amis donné détail
près au tc risqué ddm arch est comme ça
maintenant le corps et livre c'est le
souhait terre c'est une robe c'est une
mode en ce fonctionnaire elle est
merveilleuse
j'ai dit aussi quelque part que vous
nous avez dit que vous détestiez que
vous adoriez tout ce qui était vieux
fatigués efféminé oui moi je n'ai je
fais des modes qui sont cons qui sont
fonctionnels qui courait sur fusionnelle
moderne je m'intéresse à la science
moderne je m'intéresse à l'avion à la
science tout ce qui est mis je
m'intéresse à la voiture sport je
m'intéresse vraiment à tout ce qui fait
la santé la jeunesse et la création de
l'esprit je ne pense pas à mon grand
père ni au romantisme anciens qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
d'ailleurs les romantiques mais étaient
des gens modernes à leur époque ils ne
sont pas nés anciens ils ne sont pas nés
romantique et quand vous dites
minet c'est une notion qui
correspondrait bien efféminé je trouve
que efféminé dans ce sens que c'est pas
du tout parce qu'on porte une chemise
rouge que vous êtes efféminé ou parce
que vous avez des cheveux longs vous
êtes efféminé napoléon lafayette les
grands généraux à les grands conquérants
ont tous été des gens aux cheveux longs
par conséquent qu'est ce que ça veut
dire efféminé c'est l'individu qui est
efféminé mais c'est pas le physique
moi je connais des gens très viril et
qui sont très efféminé je connais des
gens très efféminé mais qui sont
vraiment des des nullités des gens très
fort en tout point de vue ça ne veut
rien dire ça non mais je vous pose la
question parce que j'ai noté quelques
peurs et ça me paraissait détruits parce
que je trouve la virilité n'a rien à
voir dans le physique absolument rien
pour vous trouver beau coup que je crois
qu'on n'est pas consciente ça je crois
que c'est difficile de dire qu'on est
beau c'est ridicule oui oui oui je me
donne pas pas de moi non un sens là non
est ce que la politique vous intéresse
un peu l'île a political oui ça
m'intéresse absolument auquel sens est
bien au point d'une sas taawun dupont
métier le fait d'une d'avoir des
contacts avec un pays permet de prévoir
des possibilités commerciales ou des
possibilités d'exportation et rapports
politiques sont donc basés sur les
échanges industriels les échanges
d'affaires je crois que la politique
c'est ça et vous avez des opinions
politiques
oui j'ai mon opinion déçu et bien non je
parle là c'est une émission qui est basé
sur la culture c'est inutile sur l'or il
est inutile que j'admire les gens qui
encouragent aller jusqu'au bout oui et
je
profonde admiration pour certaines
personnes c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il
suit avec une grande ferveur ont fait
savoir qu'ils aient bien je n'ai pas à
vous dire je crois que j'ai compris je
vous ai compris pourquoi parle-t-on de
vos mains les ans dès jeudi ça dans
trois journaux ou on n'a rien de spécial
et marées son cas réels sont loués sont
très clairs sur des vins qui ont
travaillé elles sont très sensibles
d'ouvriers n'ayant absolument ça oui ok
rillaer la matière et travailler avec
mes mains n'oubliez pas et brice et se
sont formés à mon image bah vidic vous
ne vous dites pas que vous ne faisiez
pas que vous ne pouviez pas que votre
loisir
c'était le travail je voudrais vous
poser votre question mais qui ne veut
pas du tout être indiscret l'amour ça a
occupé une place à 13 en temps je crois
que l'amour c'est très très important il
faut être très discret jeux prince et là
les sentiments doivent être discret je
pense est une des qualités essentielles
mais je crois tout individu a besoin
d'amour qui lie à place dans votre vie
pour l'amour mais sûrement entre sur le
terrain on est absolument vous êtes vous
posé à ce qu'enfin de de jeanne moreau
et pas du tout pourquoi est-ce que je
crois vous et moi je crois que ma
liaison et john ware a été publique je
n'ai aucune raison de face toute façon
c'est suffisamment ont écrit sur les
genoux et ça a été une compagne exquis
ces merveilleuses vous avez aimé
oui et je l'admiré fondé mans et de 2,2
forme d'admiration vous l'aimiez
pourquoi et bien parce qu'elle est elle
il ya je crois qu'elle correspondait à
l'idéal féminin de qui correspondait à
ce que j'aime
enfin on quand on aime une personne
c'est parce qu'on les trouve des
qualités qui vous donnent satisfaction
lesquels je crois qu'elle a elle a des
qualités de deux mères elle a des
qualités de femme d'intérieur elle a des
qualités d'intelligence et là elle a un
grand talent et un pouvoir de feu d'être
différente et chaque fois la mène tout
en étant à des facettes complètement
posée selon l'humeur la journée le lieu
elle est d'une humeur exquis si elle le
désire enfin je crois qu'elle a elle a
un attrait exceptionnel enfin je pense
que tu parles salal dit elle disait très
souvent à cette époque
souhaitez vous épousez oui en effet nous
avons failli nous marier voilà ça ne
s'est pas fait je crois que là les
choses se brise enfin il ya un
commencement et il ya parfois une la vie
est très difficile en semaine dans les
sentiments c'est une chose qui est je ne
suis je suis dans l'absolu dans le sens
que j'aime les êtres dans l'absolu et à
partir du moment où certaines choses ne
correspond pas à ce que j'attends d'eux
eh bien peut-être que moi même je suis
un personnage très difficile ne croyez
pas je crois si simple à vivre
j'ai une apparence puisque être mais je
suis très exigeant et pour moi-même et
d'autant plus pour les autres ce qui
fait que vivre avec une personne toute
une vie s'il n'ya pas le mariage ou s'il
n'y a pas des enfants
je crois que c'est assez très difficile
enfin ce supporter si vous est donc tous
et il faut avant tout accepter les
autres n'est ce pas c'est à dire
accepter tous les défauts des autres
lorsque les qualités on n'en parle pas
par conséquent je suis prêt à accepter
tous les défauts mais est ce que l'on
accepte les miens et voilà c'est la
question
alors on peut vous imaginez seule la
nuit c'est oui au mieux à deux heures du
matin on n'est que lors des dix queen
bien une sonorité qui est très fier très
bien enfin je me plais la nuit si oui
j'aime ma maison ça fait partie de mon
équilibre moral m
indispensable est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de votre vie oui je crois que
j'ai satisfaction dans ce que j'ai voulu
faire oui je ne me plains jamais
d'ailleurs c'est léger c'est de parer à
toutes les difficultés
mais tout ce qui est difficultés je n'en
avais par personne pour que les ennuis
faut les garder pour soi
les joueurs les partages essayer de
partager des ennuis non parce que des
ennuis ennuis les autres vraiment j'ai
constaté souvent que le fait de faire
part de ses difficultés
finalement les gens écoutent d'une
oreille et ça désarçonne mais je le
comprends parfaitement bien car les
ennuis des autres par quelques personnes
très très intime
dans le fond c'est un sujet de
conversation mais ça n'a pas de
conséquence face troqué choses
importantes dans les ennuis des
préférences de les garder pour soi et il
arrivait à les dissiper ou à les
dissimuler le maximum alors ne parlons
pas d'ennuis parlons de soucis sens
métaphysique du terme
je suis si les outils vendée u
maintenant de enfin disons que je mets
ma situation et evra est plus tout y est
enfin plutôt agréable mais j'ai eu des
soucis énormément ne croyez pas tout
cette maison aussi importantes soient
construction souci est ce qu'il ya une
est ce que vous considérez qu'il y à une
tarte échec dans votre vie je n'ai que
l'échec des parfums car je n'ai jamais
eu vraiment le temps de m'en occuper
mais maintenant les parfums repartent
une manière assez près très brillante
avec une grande diffusion sur l'amérique
par cholton part qu'aucun fait part
[Musique]
par une grosse chose et je crois que
maintenant ça va repartir d'une manière
je n'ai pas eu non vraiment dans mon
travail dans ma vie privée non plus on
également
je n'ai pas eu d'échec enfin je crois
que je n'ai que j'ai mérité dans ce sens
que si j'ai eu des difficultés peut-être
que j'en étais pas je t'ai pas à la
hauteur de 2 de leurs données ne le
retrouver peut-être une solution aussi
bien dans les sentiments que dans les
queues dans les affaires je crois que je
suis responsable de ce que j'ai fait et
dans le biais dans le mal enfin je crois
que ça c'est très bien mais ce que vous
ne considérez pas sur un plan plus
général que toute vie même la plus
réussie on porte en soi même il
paraissait enfin écoutez j'ai grillé les
étapes dans le sens qu'il est certain
que je demande très grande solitude des
moments de grandes d'un état un état
d'ailleurs qui ne met pas désagréable
jeu là vous mais je crois que la
réussite est une chose essentielle et en
même temps s'aperçoit que finalement la
vie tout ça et fugitif en somme c'était
un but mais ce n'est pas je crois que en
effet fermement je me dis pourquoi tout
ça pour qui pour quoi puisque dans son
snack donc ce n'est quand même en de la
vie et ont très souvent peu la vie en
fin d année passée on s'aperçoit que
peut-être on a au détriment d'autres
choses on a sacrifié son temps mais
finalement que ce soit dans maintenant
va tout ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait avec
joie et ma foi socialement socialement
je suis dans un milieu très parisien jeu
non je crois que ma vie sociale et je
suppose réussi en tout cas je la trouve
réussi ma vie de travail réussi ma vie
sentimentale également la vue des échecs
mais mais enfin par rapport à d'autres
je trouve que j'ai finalement dire j'ai
une vie d'une manière beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus vrai je suis un caractère
extrêmement droit et surtout traître
très imparfaite absolument partiale et
et je trouve que ma vie est une vie qui
a été à une vie de travail bien sûr
mehdi travail dans la joie et dans la
satisfaction par conséquent c'était un
loisir et la mort et bien la mort qui
n'a peur de la mort mais je crois que l
étain et un instant enfin elle était
présente à tout moment qui demain
peut-être ce que demain je serai mort
veut d'être que je ferais écrasé ou 1 je
trouve que la mort est là c est un et
c'est une manière de ne plus être qui
qui est le sort de tous les individus
enfin vous y pensez
je n'y pense assez rarement jouée à dire
lorsque je vois autour de moi des
accidents de voiture ou où des êtres qui
me sont prêts ou que même des employés
enfin des choses qui sont plutôt
émouvantes comme par exemple pour un
détail de haute couture j'ai eu la
petite sainte catherine que j'ai coiffé
cette année est bien en surtemps de de
la fête que nous lui avons faite pour
elle elle est rentrée chez elle avec son
fiancé elle est morte sur le chemin du
retour
évidemment il est certain que dd
problème de cet ordre à toute échelle
tout de même parfois vous dise dans son
la ville très peu enfin il fallait
penser à la mort en permanence pourquoi
vivre et vous vous préoccupez vous avez
pensé à ce que deviendrait notre
président dans tous les cas un coup je
suis écouté j'ai formé des cadres j'ai
un jeune cara qui est tendre l'hiver
autour de moi qu'ils étaient formés
depuis 15 ans j'ai d'autres et puma fera
après moi et bien un dior
malheureusement est mort la maison
continue et puis quelle importance pour
moi qu'elle continuerait ne continue pas
je propose le problème si je j'ai la
chance de vivre longtemps gens on aurait
tous les avantages si je disparais bien
la fois les autres en profiteront et mon
nom est certaine s'éteindra pas du jour
au lendemain il est trop vaste mais ma
foi pour les multis façon je crois que
rien n'avait aucune solution dans ces
cas là
[Musique]